hello good morning this is sky news
breakfast live from medicare the main
border crossing between poland and
ukraine and the route out of the country
for ukrainians escaping the conflict
we'll bring you all the latest
throughout the morning as russia's
invasion of ukraine takes another
worrying turn
europe's biggest nuclear power plant is
shelled as russian targets ukraine's
energy infrastructure prompting a
chilling warning from ukraine's
president
if there is an explosion that's the end
for everyone the end for europe the
evacuation of europe
boris johnson says russia's attack on a
nuclear power station could threaten the
safety of all of europe
as russia steps up the assault on
ukraine cities western ministers will
hold crisis talks today
the home secretary prepares to meet
ukrainian refugees on the polish border
as the government faces pressure to do
more to help those escaping
and that's as the stream of refugees
fleeing the fighting shows no sign of
abating with more than a million people
leaving ukraine
i'm live in la viv in western ukraine as
thousands upon thousands of people
continue to arrive here trying to escape
the russian attack on the east of this
country
the u.s joins britain in sanctioning
russian oligarchs and more companies
shun russia piling more financial pain
on moscow
[Music]
hello good morning from medicare we're
on the border between poland and ukraine
where many of the more than a million
people fleeing the fighting have been
arriving over the last few days
this morning there's been another
disturbing development in the conflicts
with russia targeting a crucial energy
producing city as it steps up its
assault on ukraine the fire apparently
broke out in an unused reactor at the
zappos sierra nuclear power plant which
is the biggest in europe after it was
shelled by russian forces
well in the last hour the ukrainian
authorities have said that the fire has
been extinguished and russian forces
have taken control of the site
ukraine has warned of a nuclear disaster
if it blows up with boris johnson saying
it could directly threaten the safety
of all of europe
well let's bring you the latest
developments the international atomic
energy agency says there's been no
change to radiation levels after a fire
at europe's biggest nuclear plant
president zielenski has warned european
leaders not to allow the death of europe
from a nuclear catastrophe while the
prime minister boris johnson says he'll
seek an emergency un security council
meeting
and this morning
foreign ministers from nato are due to
meet to discuss the crisis greg milan
has this report
as if this crisis weren't dire enough
these images hold the prospect of a
whole new horror in ukraine the shelling
of the largest nuclear power plant of
its kind in europe causing a fire no one
here needs any reminder of the potential
for nuclear catastrophe and ukraine's
president said this took the war into
dangerous new territory
if there is an explosion that's the end
for everyone the end for europe the
evacuation of europe only urgent action
by europe can stop the russian troops do
not allow the death of europe from a
catastrophe at a nuclear power station
the attack on ukraine's infrastructure
is just one of multiple fronts in an
invasion that vladimir putin says is
going to plan
this is what that looks like apartment
buildings in the town of borodianca 50
kilometers from the capital kiev still
smoldering the road littered with the
debris of an assault that russia says is
not targeting civilians but it is in the
major cities that the fighting has
intensified
russia's defence ministry released these
pictures along with claims to have
destroyed hundreds of military targets
ukraine says that troops from belarus
have now been given the go-ahead to join
the russian invasion
lined up against them is condemnation
from around the globe the u.s secretary
of state embarking on another european
tour to show russia the west remains
united
in washington the president tightened
the sanctioned pressure on moscow
today i'm announcing that we're adding
dozens of names to the list including
one of russia's wealthiest billionaires
and i'm
banning travel to america by
by more than
50 russian oligarchs their families and
their close associates
it's ordinary russians feeling that
pressure so far ikea the latest foreign
company to close its doors as all over
europe countries are throwing open
theirs more than a million refugees have
left in the first week crossing the
border to safety but uncertainty a
massive humanitarian operation spreading
across eastern europe one that will need
to cope with much much more in the weeks
to come
when you consider what they've left
behind how must this show of humanity
feel such a welcome for people who have
no idea when
if ever they'll go back to those they've
left behind
greg milam sky news
[Music]
well prime minister boris johnson has
warned that the whole of europe is at
threat by what has happened the shelling
of this nuclear plant the prime minister
said i've just spoken with zielinski
that is of course the president of
ukraine about the gravely concerning
situation at the
zappo russia nuclear plant station
russia must immediately cease its attack
on the power station and allow
unfettered access for emergency services
to the plant
well as we've heard russian forces have
attacked this plant in southeast ukraine
it is part of an increasingly violent
campaign which has ramped up in the last
48 hours overnight a fire broke out at a
training building outside the zapparosha
nuclear power station in southeastern
ukraine near the city of ennerhada it's
europe's largest nuclear plant and among
the top 10 biggest in the world
responsible for 20 of all of ukraine's
electricity it has now reportedly been
seized by russian forces
moscow has launched hundreds of missiles
and artillery attacks on cities and
other sites around the country making
significant gains in the south this week
russia announced the capture of the
southern city of kersen a vital black
sea port of 280 thousand people
and heavy fighting continues on the
outskirts of the strategic port of
mariopol the city has no water or power
supply and the mayor says russia has cut
all rail links describing what's
happening there as genocide
well many of those fleeing fighting have
yet to leave ukraine and have sought
refuge in the country's western city lev
our europe correspondent adam parsons
joins me now from there and adam there
must be enormous concern where you are
about what has happened at this power
station and what is continuing to happen
in kirsten
yeah absolutely and i think one of the
one of the indications of this war
across the country is that although
we're a long way from the fighting here
the ripples of that the nervousness the
anxiety
are etched in a lot of people's faces
here now on the situation the nuclear
power plant
clearly lots of contradictory
information coming out that the latest
information that i have that i
rely on is that actually there's no
critical incident has been declared that
the fire has been extinguished that some
parts of that nuclear power plant are so
are still operational
some is out some has been
shut down but
what is evident is that there is
enormous natural nervousness
whenever you have something
as potentially catastrophically
dangerous as a nuclear power plant
caught between
two warring armies uh and i think the
fact that the international inspectors
are not going to be able to get to this
power station ukraine has its own
inspectorate which at the moment is
saying that the the plant is safe but
of course in real time how do you
monitor this
we have been discussing in in recent
days would russia actually use nuclear
weapons
evidently there is no desire
among the west for among anybody frankly
among anybody sane for nuclear weapons
to be used in this conflict similarly
you would say
anybody rational would think that when
you have a nuclear power plant your
number one objective is to take care of
that i don't think we're at the point
now where anyone is going to play fast
and loose
uh with this but it is in the middle
uh of a uh of a war zone so on that
front that attack that attack on on
kirsten as well reverberates
here because you have people who are
fleeing this country also those who are
staying here and i have to say
the gradual erosion of people's mental
health across this country is something
that you see this is
a nation where people are increasingly
feeling frazzled
[Laughter]
and how
how are they they managing you know we
saw so many of them yesterday arriving
in poland and so they're coming to where
you are in the hope of either maybe
staying in the west of ukraine or moving
across the border into poland and then
further on i mean you say they are
frazzled but but how long can can
people go on like this
well the the estimates from the united
nations are that that well over a
million people have now left but that
number could go up to four million and i
have to say one thing
that strikes me as the order of this
process is is pretty remarkable there is
no chaos you'll see snapshots of it of
course you are but actually inside this
station when i've been in there and
trains have been departing it's been
very well managed you have a lot of
military personnel in there a lot of
police and when we came this morning
this is new uh up to yesterday it was a
free for all to be blunt to get into
this station now
there is this this long snaking cue
that's coming out of the station
and going
all the way down this down this line
here
as we have seen
all over uh ukraine the people fleeing
are
in every case women
and children and pensioners although
it's predominantly women and children a
lot of the older ukrainians i think
either want to stay put they'd have no
desire
dislocate themselves or there are older
men who want to stay and try and sign up
there's ukraine has an army of 200 000
people
by some estimates it has a reservist
force of 900 000 and these are people
mobilizing
in force it's quite feasible that at
some point ukraine will have
over a million
uh people in active service and this
queue goes on
and on
and on these are people trying to get
out
of here these i suspect are all people
who are trying to come in your direction
jane they're trying to get out of the
country because that there is a line
that goes from lev to poland now one of
the logistic challenges they face i've
been on that train is that
it's only one line it's a line in and a
line out so if the train gets delayed
going out it gums everything
coming back again it's not an express
service by any way not all of these
people are going to get on one train but
they will be running that train
constantly in and out
all day
long amidst all the grim let's show you
something here ukrainians love their
pets they absolutely love uh their
animals
and uh you see again and again
pets
some of them very friendly some of them
less so uh
and they're carrying their dogs and
their cats with them
uh out of this country i spoke to
someone yesterday who didn't have very
much but they did have their cat uh in a
box and i said you haven't got many
possessions they said i've got the most
important one
right here
but this kind of sea of humanity
continues on and i think when i first
came here
there was almost
a sense i won't use adventure it's not a
venture it's it's it's a horrible
horrendous situation but there were
people who were still had energy
still had a kind of vibrancy and a
desire to get going i think we are now
at a stage where these people are
invariably
exhausted um i met a woman called jean
yesterday who is in a shelter in the
middle of the town a theater that's been
converted into uh into a refugee center
she spent six days
sleeping in a metro station in kharkiv
and has fled now
here
i'm not sure i've ever seen anyone who
is quite so exhausted in my life and
that is a picture that
is facing across ukraine it's a it's a
nation
that is wiped out and frantic and
desperately needs help
yeah absolutely adam and it's something
we've seen on the faces of those
arriving here in poland as well thanks
so much for that update from inside
ukraine well in the last few moments
we've had an update from the ministry of
defense they've given us uh some
information in the form of a daily
briefing and they are saying that the
zaparosha nuclear plant they too have
found that radiation coming from there
from their sources is within normal
limits
they are also saying that mario paul
on the south coast does remain under
ukrainian control but they think it is
likely to have been encircled by russian
forces
and that the city's civilian
infrastructure has been subjected in
their words to intense russian strikes
well let's uh talk now to uh dominic
waghorn our international affairs editor
he's in moscow for us
and dominic we saw president putin
talking to the nation again yesterday um
what is the feeling about uh his state
of mind and where this could go next
well it was described jane um by one
western official yesterday is
he is rational but only within his own
sort of frame of reference and that
frame of reference is i think a narrower
and narrower frame or space and it's
kind of informed by the generals and the
intelligence people around him um who
are all telling him still i think and
have been telling him for a while the
west is out to get him and wants to
topple his regime so i think the hopes
that the west has been harboring that
the sanctions that the pressure would
make him think again certainly would
dash by what we heard from him on that
televised address last night but also in
his phone call with emmanuel macron the
french president whose official said
there was nothing reassuring to come out
of that uh phone call i think we get a
very clear picture of of his mind of his
intentions from both of uh those um
events the phone call and the address
and i think the most disturbing thing
about the address
and from the phone call is that he
clearly seems to believe his own
propaganda it's a pretty flimsy pretext
on which he's going to war a war that
could destroy one country and probably
destroy his own economy or do a huge
amount of damage to it but it is a
pretext he seems to be
believing in and he believes that he's
fighting a neo-nazi regime even though
its president is jewish he believes that
ukraine is a military threat to russia
even though russia has overwhelming
advantage militarily he also believes
ukrainians and the russians he repeated
this last night are one people and he
said that the ukrainians have been
brainwashed as if he one man knows
better than the effects of the entire
nation that has decided to move further
westward so despite all that sort of i
mean you could call it lies you could
call it fantasy or deluded which was
what macron uh told putin last night it
is something he seems to believe in he's
doubling down he's pressing on
regardless and the cost is going to be
enormous for ukraine and for his own
country and we're looking i think at a
protracted grinding war the west piling
on ukraine's side supplying weapons
russia pushing in with all its military
might
with no real end in sight
and dominic as we talked to you uh we're
seeing liz trust the foreign secretary
arriving in brussels more diplomacy
today she's meeting jen stoltenberg and
anthony blinken there
to see if they can find any way forward
in this conflict but
we we also heard yesterday that that
there have been a lot more clamp downs
again on free speech on the media in
moscow
we saw the story about some children
being arrested for laying flowers at the
ukrainian embassy or trying to
what is the state of mind as as far as
you're able to glean it off the russian
people about what's happening
um i i think it's deepening concern but
it depends on who you speak to i think a
lot of russians get their news from the
official state media and they're being
told still this is a limited military
operation it's necessary to deal with
the neo-nazis in ukraine and a lot of
them believe that and i think if you're
out of the cities uh you're less
concerned about sanctions you probably
grow your own vegetables you're probably
poor anyway and you do believe your
government is doing the right thing i
think if you're metropolitan if you live
in cities if you're better educated
you're really concerned i think ordinary
people are getting a sense though that
this is economically going to affect
them things like already
short supplies in pharmacies uh people
obviously not be able to get apple
iphones or be able to pay on apple pay i
think it's a gradual process and
obviously the ruble
uh crashing is obviously of concern as
well it's going to take a while for the
penny to drop but i think russians are
concerned about that but they are
believing a lot of them still the
propaganda being told by vladimir putin
and the key question really is is he
being affected by this is he worried it
doesn't seem to be the case because i
think if you look at strongmen recently
look at maduro in venezuela look at the
ayatollahs in iran actually sanctions do
help them i mean if you talk to western
diplomats i'll tell you there's a pretty
narrow range of options none of them are
very good but something has to be done
and sanctions are the best
option but there is a huge danger that
they're going to affect russian people a
lot more than that kind of narrow
securocrat elite surrounding putin and
the president himself he can dig in and
if he does become more oppressive which
seems as you're saying much more likely
we might well see a state of emergency
declared or other emergency laws he's
going to be able to put the country on a
war footing to clear any criticis
criticism and dissent treasonous and
that's going to i think entrench him in
power and allow him more space and
freedom to carry on with this war
okay dominic thanks so much for that
update from moscow
well let's just remind you of some of
the numbers over a million people have
fled neighboring countries so far and
that number is rising by the hour
so 90 000 have already traveled into
western europe but the largest number
have crossed the border into poland
around half a million people
nearly 140 000 have got a hungary which
has changed its hardline policy on
accepting refugees
neighboring moldova has received now
nearly a hundred thousand people and
over 79 000 have crossed into slovakia
while the romanian authorities say more
than 150 000 people have arrived from
ukraine
[Music]
well let's turn back to the uk now and
the deputy prime minister dominic rabb
joins me now live from westminster good
to talk to you this morning sir um let's
just start straight away with the
zaparossa nuclear plant and the attack
on it um we have heard just now from the
ministry of defense that radiation
levels are normal but how concerned are
you about the fact that that this plant
was
hit do you think it was targeted or was
this this this just part of warfare
well at the very
at the very least it was clearly a
reckless bombardment of a very sensitive
and precarious and dangerous facility
and the fact that the russians kept
bombarding it after
um
there was the fire and the ukrainian
emergency rescue team were trying to get
to that uh it makes it doubly
reprehensible and the prime minister's
been very clear on this uh he's called
for an emergency meeting of the un
security council
in new york uh in order to
ramp up the pressure on these appalling
tactics that we're seeing from the
kremlin but also to make sure we're
supporting the ukrainian government in
any way we can
does this perhaps suggest to you that
president putin is serious about nuclear
war
i think the way i would read it is that
the early part of his military campaign
has stuttered and stumbled it's not been
as effective uh i think there's been a
lot of pushback um
amongst the russians that this isn't
what they uh had expected this isn't
what he'd sold he'd said it would be a
cake walk into ukraine that clearly
hasn't happened and he's responding with
ever more heavy-handed and brutal
tactics and that is also i think a
reflection of the fact that the
international community has been more
resolute than perhaps he'd expected with
the concerted package of sanctions which
has had a a a very uh an initially very
powerful impact on for example the
russian ruble the russian stock market
they've had to in double interest rates
uh so we will continue to
starve the finances that
fund putin's war machine and support the
ukrainians in their
their their courageous defense against
this illegal invasion
but whilst it may well be impacted on
some russians it doesn't seem to be
changing president putin's mind any does
it
well it won't happen overnight we need
to keep up the pressure
which is why we're taking the actions
that we're taking but it has had an
immediate impact and of course
and we need to show the strategic
stamina to see this through in ukraine
and of course it is dawning on
many whether it's the conscripts
who are out there in ukraine told that
they were a peacekeeping force facing
fearsome resistance
receiving illegal orders to attack
civilian targets which could end
up seeing them
in the dock of a court or even
imprisoned for war crimes and of course
those who are bankrolling putin are
being hit where it hurts as well but
you're right to say it's not going to
happen overnight i think we need to get
set
for a much longer protracted crisis in
you
in ukraine and we'll need to have the
stamina with our international partners
for that
are you concerned about president
putin's state of mind
i look i think it's clearly irrational
even if i looked at it through the
narrowest russian
uh perspective clearly counterproductive
to russian interests and you can see
that in the economic consequences and i
believe you'll see that in the
the casualties that they're taking will
continue to take um i've got no idea i'm
not a psychiatrist but it is clearly a
rational counterproductive for russians
let alone the impact the horrific impact
it's having on the people of your
ukraine and the wider nervousness we've
all got now around
regional security
how concerned are you about president
zielenski in ukraine and and what help
can the uk give to him because he has
become such a galvanizing figure quite
an inspirational figure inside ukraine
we know that he has been targeted uh by
russian forces if he were to be
attacked or if he was forced to leave
what impact do you think that would have
on the conflict
well we know that the
russian playbook has involved targeted
assassinations we've seen that in the
streets of salisbury in 2018 so i i
think we do need to support uh president
zlenski in every way we can of course we
give him advice
and we'll be careful about divulging too
much of that but we also give him
military hardware we've given his um
troops uh training under operation
orbital
and there's a a massive package of
economic and humanitarian support for
him as well um so we won't i won't go
into too much uh of some of the finer
details of it but we are willing to do
whatever it takes to support uh the
ukrainian defense and indeed uh the
president in uh what is a very
courageous stance that he's taking
what does that mean
i'll just explain to you what it
involves
you won't give us any more details on
exactly what the uk is sending to help
ukrainians on this front
we've provided anti-tank
hardware
we're continuing and willing to provide
other military hardware to allow
ukrainians to defend themselves
we provided humanitarian assistance on
top of the economic assistance to deal
with obviously the energy pressures
that they will face um
and we'll look across the board at what
else we can do and we're going to
support the international criminal court
the chief prosecutor i believe is going
to ukraine if we can support that
accountability
and it's critical that evidence of war
crimes is preserved so that those
responsible right across the chain of
command can be held accountable so from
from from war crimes through to
humanitarian assistance through to the
hardware to defend the streets and the
cities of ukraine we will provide
whatever we can and of course
the most important thing is to work with
our allies to make it as effective as
possible
you mentioned sanctions let's go back
back to them france and germany have
already started seizing oligarchs yachts
shouldn't we be seizing property as tom
tougenhaard has suggested
well we have got sanctions on over a
hundred entities you've seen two
individuals isn't oven chivalrous
overnight
but what we're doing is making sure we
take the most effective measures we need
evidence to seize uh property um and
just to give you one illustration
because it's been put about that we're
slow or we're lagging behind actually um
we've sanctioned more russian banks than
the eu including the biggest russian
banks burbank
we've prevented
millions of russian companies from being
listed in the uk or raising loans in the
uk
and we will look carefully at how we can
expedite and strengthen all the the the
powers that we've got so just to give
you two examples on monday we're going
to be putting through at pace the
economic crimes bill which will
strengthen the unexplained wealth orders
and create greater transparency around
who owns foreign-owned companies who is
the ultimate owner uh in order for us to
take faster and more effective measures
but we've got one of the most robust and
rigorous sanctions regimes in the world
we do need to have a legal basis and
evidence to take those measures
otherwise you end up tripping up and
that just gives a propaganda coup to
whoever we want to target and of course
i would also just say we're not
targeting all international finance
coming into the uk we want to be open to
that we're not targeting blanket
russian uh money we are targeting
the corrupt the kleptocrats and those
linked to putin and his war machine and
uh it's very important that we are
targeted in what we do because that's
the most effective way to increase the
squeeze on vladimir putin and his war
machine
back in 2010 the conservative government
changed the visa system to encourage
more high net worth individuals to come
into the uk in hindsight do you think
that that was possibly an error that
that possibly has has led to a blind eye
being turned to some
russian money that perhaps shouldn't
have done coming into the uk
well the home sector has already dealt
with the tier 1
visas and it's true to say that we want
to be open to business and open to
international investment it's part of
our usp and global britain but at the
same time we have led the way in taking
targeted sanctions just to give you two
further illustrations particularly
relevant to russia as foreign secretary
i introduced the sergey magnitsky
sanction regime for human rights abuses
asset visas asset freezes and visa bans
and we extended it to corruption so we
have been at the vanguard of striking
this balance between being an open
economy but not allowing dirty money and
and those with blood on their hands to
to place their assets here and we're
strengthening that even further
okay
good to talk to you dominic rob thanks
very much for joining us today
well let's bring in skies ali fortescue
who joins me now from west kent's
wednesday clearly concern uh ali about
what is happening in russia and in
ukraine but from mr raab
the hope really that diplomacy is still
going to win through
yeah that's right he called the events
at the nuclear power plant yesterday
reckless um i think what was
particularly interesting was hearing
dominic responding to that criticism
about britain not acting quickly enough
on russian oligarchs not acting quickly
enough on sanctions and he said that
actually we have sanctioned more russian
banks than the european union but when
it comes to individuals we know that the
european union are well ahead of us they
have sanctioned
26 individuals which is double uh the
number of russians that have been
sanctioned by britain even though of
course we have two more names yesterday
joining
the government's list uh alesha usmanov
uh an eagle uh shovel of two um more men
two more russian billionaires worth
saying
one of their
yachts was seized two yesterday in
germany
and
now they will see their assets frozen in
britain won't be able to come to the uk
and british
people individuals and businesses won't
be able to deal with them anymore so um
he pointed to those two new names
joining the list but i think there will
still be pressure on the government he
pointed to um to the economic crime bill
which is going to be in parliament on
monday but um that is basically about
sort of making it easier to unmask who
actually is behind
the money who actually owns properties
um by making them join a register
but there is an 18-month grace period
for that and that is something that has
been criticized by
labour who say that that is far too much
time gives people um time to to wiggle
out of it and um and that is something
that we know the government are looking
at but dominic robb did point to the
economic
crime bill he also said that we need
evidence to seize property we need a
legal basis he said and that of course
is something the government have pointed
to before the fact that they need um to
follow due legal process and of course
when they're dealing with people who
have deep pockets
and who potentially could
could bring a long convoluted expensive
legal battle that is obviously a big
challenge that the government want to
avoid but um they are facing pressure
the lib dems saying that they should and
some conservative backbenchers like tom
tougandahar saying that they should
seize properties rather than just
freezing assets uh that's something that
reportedly michael gove might be looking
at but all of this and the criticism is
is taking far too long
okay ali good to talk to you thanks very
much adivolsky there in westminster for
us
well as we've been hearing more than a
million refugees have now crossed the
ukrainian border into neighbouring
countries germany is beginning to
welcome thousands through its own border
skies sadia chowdhury reports how those
in berlin are making displaced
ukrainians feel at home
german hospitality that matches german
efficiency
and when the two come together the
result is this
a fully organized reception area here at
berlin station for the hundreds of
ukrainian refugees arriving
from the poland ukraine border
like anastasia whose journey has already
taken nearly a hundred hours i came with
my with my mother and
now we feel like we are homeless
we ex exactly we are homeless in this
moment and we should
handle
basic things we have no staff we have no
money we have no anything now in scenes
reminiscent of seven years ago when
germans line stations to welcome syrian
refugees
berlin central is paved with donations
clothes
toys
hot drinks
a million or so refugees have already
crossed from ukraine into the european
union in eastern poland slovakia and
hungary and northern romania
in germany it started as a trickle of a
few hundred a day
it's now grown into a steady flow of
more than a thousand people
we have to run into the basement once or
twice a day due to air strikes nobody
knows when it happens so you have to
have everything ready documents food and
that's not a life
the deutsche bahn train company has made
travel free for refugees coming from
poland and around the country
a small gesture perhaps but one that
offers significant relief
sadia chowdhury sky news
well i'm not joined now by the chief
executive of the refugee council enver
solomon uh good to talk to you today and
put it in context for us we had the un
yesterday saying that this was the the
fastest movement of refugees this
century how big potentially could this
be
this could be very big it's quite
extraordinary uh the numbers that the un
are talking about are around about four
million and possibly as many as seven
million if you just think the fact that
in eight days that's just eight days a
million people have been on the move and
crossed the borders of ukraine into
neighboring countries in another eight
days or another ten days or two weeks we
could easily have double that number and
the numbers could go on rising and these
are people who are in in great need and
the world needs to step up and support
them europe and the uk need to play its
part providing them with sanctuary and
supporting them at this time of a
terrible human tragedy unfolding
the uk says it is doing what it can we
just spoke to to dominic
a short time ago um
what would you like to see the
government doing more
well i think it's an important first
step they've made
by relaxing the visa rules for people
that have family members and they've
also announced what they're describing
as a humanitarian sponsorship pathway
but it's not clear
how that humanitarian pathway is going
to work and our concern
is that actually the numbers that the uk
does welcome
might not be that very hard that high
what we would like to see is the
government considering more flexibility
and that flexibility could
be put in place by allowing any
ukrainian to quickly apply for what's
known as a humanitarian visa so they
could come to the uk
and they could be welcomed to stay in
the uk
and give them permission to be here for
as long as they need to be here at the
same time i think it's absolutely
critical because this conflict is likely
to play out it's likely to become
protracted that's what i think the
expectation is and if that is the case
we could see millions
of refugees in neighboring countries
sometimes very poor neighboring
countries like moldavia one of the
poorest countries in europe and if
that's the case it's critical
that in the longer term we work with the
un and we have a resettlement program in
the way that we did for syrians to come
to the uk
what do you make of the home secretary
saying that the uk's reluctance to to
expand it so quickly is due to in her
words the strongest security advice what
do you think she's concerned about
well i think one needs to ask government
about that i'm not privy to that
information
i don't doubt that there are concerns in
the same way
that during the the summer last year
when the horrendous situation played out
in afghanistan and we had to evacuate
thousands of people there were also
security concerns then and previously
there were concerns with syria so
back in 2005 so i don't doubt that there
are concerns but i think there's ways
around these concerns you can carry out
biometric tests
easily by ensuring that people who then
arrive in the uk are properly checked so
that any measures can be taken to ensure
that the uk is protected from it from
any individuals that might pose a threat
to the uk
are you concerned that if the uk doesn't
allow more ukrainians in that they
will join
the people that we've seen for example
trying to get across the channel on
boats trying to to get across the
channel in lorries and things like that
or do you think that that most
ukrainians who've left will will as you
say stay in countries closer to ukraine
well the reality is with situations like
this and the same happened with syria
back in 2015 is that lots of people do
stay in neighboring countries because
they want to try and get back to their
homeland as soon as possible but there
are also many that want to move to other
countries to safe countries to rebuild
their lives and if we don't have
enough safe routes for people to get to
the uk the reality is is that some will
make journeys overland and some could
end up coming through france taking very
dangerous journeys
and that very dangerous journey across
the world's most busiest shipping lane
across the channel to the uk and it's
absolutely imperative that people
who want to come to the uk are given the
opportunity to do so safely that's why
our concern is that what the government
has announced so far
might not necessarily provide
enough of a safe route for ukrainians
it's not clear because we don't have the
full details on this humanitarian
sponsorship scheme yet
but our concern is that it could result
in in a limited number of people being
able to come because of the bureaucracy
of the bureaucracy of the scheme might
just make it too complicated so i think
it's imperative the government is more
flexible going forward and looks at very
quick ways that people can apply for for
what for what is known as a humanitarian
visa to come to the uk to reach safety
here to rebuild their lives if they want
to do that
investment from the refugee council
thanks a lot for joining us this morning
for the foreign secretary liz truss and
the u.s secretary of state anthony
blinken are among those attending an
urgent meeting of eu foreign ministers
today nato foreign ministers are also
holding emergency talks sky's laura
bundock joins me now from brussels
laura it feels like i'm asking you the
same question every time we speak but
it's there is there is more diplomacy
and there is the possibility of more
sanctions
what have the diplomats got in their
arsenal that they think they could try
now to deploy today
i think that's all to be discussed and
debated today um this morning at nato
foreign ministers here at gathering uh
to discuss the situation in ukraine and
to look at what more the alliance can do
to support ukraine it's very clear the
foreign secretary liz trust believes
more can be done and we've already
heard how nato is bolstering its eastern
flank liz trust was in lithuania
yesterday she met her counterparts from
the baltic states to look at the
situation for them and to discuss what
more nato could do and i think she'll be
coming here to nato with a very clear
message that
nato needs to respond further it's
already engaged and is using uh the nato
response force uh that's french troops
arriving in romania but i think there is
certainly a feeling um from the uk that
nato can go further with that and in
this enormous day of diplomacy it
doesn't just end in at nato there's a
meeting of g7 leaders due to take place
and then towards the end of the day the
foreign affairs council of the european
union meeting and it's inviting its u.s
canadian
and ukrainian counterparts as well as
liz trust she'll be the first uk
minister to attend a foreign affairs a
meeting in brussels since brexit would
be interesting to hear by video link the
ukrainian foreign minister and i think
he's expected to make a big plea for
more support to the ukraine's military
operation particularly when it comes to
aircraft no aircraft have been provided
by the eu yet and i think that's what he
he we will hear from him later but liz
trust not mixing her words when she says
to want to send strong support for the
ukraine while tightening the vice on
putin's war machine as she put it jane
laura thanks a lot
well russian politicians will today
consider proposals to punish people with
up to 15 years in prison for
disseminating what is deemed to be false
information about the russian armed
forces
i'm joined now by a former special
adviser to the foreign minister of
ukraine cormac smith and cormac
good to talk to you the bill that the
russian parliament have debated uh in in
their words it would punish those who
distort the purpose role and tasks of
russian armed forces during special
military and other operations
what does this mean and how dangerous do
you think it is
yeah good morning and thank you for the
opportunity this bill i believe goes to
the absolute heart of putin's
problem with ukraine i think we've
already seen um the um that the absolute
false narratives and lies of denazifying
ukraine and
demilitarizing ukraine because it is a
threat to russia i think we've i think
we've with the world has seen those
those for the thin lies that they are
what putin fears and what he has always
feared is a democratic strong successful
and free ukraine on his doorstep
because that
is a threat
to his position in the kremlin because
it is likely to it is likely to
encourage and to give um energy
um to his own people who have been
who have been severely repressed and
this is one more repressive measure
russia is a country that lies on an
industrial scale that was a phrase that
my foreign minister pablo klimkin was
very very keen um to use when i when we
worked together and there are two there
are two points they use lies
strategically there is what they
broadcast in terms of false narratives
from the kremlin right down through the
likes of orti and sputnik and so forth
but on the other side is the absolute
iron grip that they have always kept on
the russian people and keeping the truth
from them and this is the latest this is
the latest step and indeed as your
moscow correspondent i think earlier
reflected he's been seen by many in the
west as a possible precursor to um um
to special and to marshall to imposing
martial law across the russian
federation which will give putin even
more repressive
powers
is there anything positive we we can
take from it i wonder if it perhaps
means that that putin is getting the
sense that he is losing the information
wall
i think the positive thing that we can
take from it is that this psychopathic
thug is fearful he is feeling fear but
unfortunately what we're seeing is he is
doubling down at every level it's
interesting um i was told late last
night by a government source there's
another draft law which is going to be
um pushed through the duma with great
haste which is and the fact that those
drafted because they're now starting to
send reinforcements in and those drafted
the first to be drafted will be the
peace protesters and i think this just
this just shows you the absolute
hatred and murderous spite
that is at the heart of this man and the
heart of um and the heart of his regime
and the in particular the hatred and the
spite that they have towards ukraine
which unfortunately has been seen with
the
barbarous and genocidal um attacks which
he has begun to unleash um on unleash on
ukraine in the last few days
just how limited are our russian
people's access to to um information i
mean we know that over the last few days
uh putin has has closed down a number of
news organizations that that were
broadcasting more independently but but
what about things like google and
wikipedia
well look when i was in um ukraine
between 2016 and 2018 there was a very
considerable piece of research done by
by the estonians and and and also the um
ukraine and crisis media center um a
very well respected organization that
set up after maidan and this research
looked at how the west was depicted
in russia and it estimated from memory
that 95 of the russian people do not get
any news from outside the russian
federation they get it and television is
hugely dominant in in russia far more so
than it is in the west where we have
many different channels and access to
the internet as you just mentioned and
um and jane is far is far wider so
there's um you know it's in the in with
the poorer people and older people he
has this iron iron grip on the um on
information that's disseminated to the
vast majority of the russian population
but that is obviously not enough for him
i think he is showing fear with this and
this is a you know draconian measure and
people have started saying you know this
will turn the russian federation into a
north korea i think we could well see
the british government
um and other governments around the
world go on to brand if this goes true
to brand actually brand russia as a
dictatorship
okay cool max smith really interesting
to talk to you thanks a lot for joining
us on sky news breakfast
the welsh government's announced it will
provide four million pounds in financial
and humanitarian aid to ukraine to help
those in desperate need well the first
minister of wales mark drakeford joins
me now from cardiff and mr drake that it
has been a hallmark of this conflict
already hasn't it the enormous
generosity of people and the willingness
of people to give
absolutely you know some of our local
authorities in wales report almost being
overwhelmed by
the volume of uh goods clothing bedding
other forms of equipment that people
have spontaneously
wanted to donate
to people who are experiencing such
awful impacts in their own lives
uh but we know that cash is what is
really needed here and now
on the ground for people who can obtain
those goods put that money to best use
and that's why the four million pounds
from the welsh government will go to the
uh disasters and emergency committee
appeal that we launched here in wales
yesterday
and and in terms of of welcoming
refugees
into wales uh how many would you would
you like to see coming to wales and what
provisions could you have for them
i think it's still really difficult to
put numbers on these things when the
position is so very volatile what we
want to see uh through the uk government
is a simple
fast
safe and legal route for people needing
to seek sanctuary elsewhere in the world
and in wales to be able to come here
wales has an ambition to be
a nation of sanctuary we welcome people
from afghanistan and from syria in
recent times
i know there will be a real
determination on the part of welsh
people to do everything we can
to welcome people from
ukraine here
when the time comes and we want that to
be as fast and as simple for them as can
possibly be put in place
what power does wales have as a devolved
nation to
introduce different policies on refugees
to the rest of the uk
well we don't have the power to uh have
different basic rules about how people
enter the united kingdom but of course
once people arrive here all the things
that they will need housing healthcare
education for children and so on all of
those things are devolved
determined and decided upon here in
wales and that's where we do very
powerfully come into the picture making
sure that we align all the things that
we can provide so that when people come
here they have
both a warm welcome in coming to wales
but also the practical help that they
will need to re-establish their lives
here when i talked with uk government
ministers yesterday you know i urge them
not to over plan things to allow those
of us who are closest to the ground to
be able to make the decisions that will
get those services to people who need
them as quickly and as effectively as
possible
now obviously not to do down wales which
is a place that ideally love and and
have visited many many times but do you
think many ukrainians really will want
to come all the way to wales the refugee
council does say that eight out of ten
refugees try to stay in the countries
next to the one that they have left i
mean
in reality we'll probably be a very
small number who will perhaps have the
inclination to make the journey or or
choose to make it their home
well we have hundreds of people from the
ukraine who live in wales already uh
they will have a family they will have
friends they will i know from speaking
to them yesterday wanted to bring people
here to wales
temporarily as i'm sure they will hope
before the position allows them to
return to the ukraine and yes i
completely recognize that the book of
people will want to stay as close to the
ukraine as possible but for those people
for whom whales could be even a
temporary a home a temporary place of
sanctuary we will want to do everything
we can to welcome them and to provide
for them
okay mark draker first minister of wales
good to talk to you thanks a lot well
coming up on sky news breakfast the
deputy prime minister we spoke to him a
little earlier he tells me that the
attack on the nuclear power plant on
ukraine is doubly reprehensible we'll
get more reaction after the break
[Music]
foreign
[Music]